violentes manifestations au venezuela
alors que les étudiants dénoncent depuis
des semaines la corruption la vie chère
et les pénuries
le leader de l'opposition leopoldo lopez
s'est rendu aux autorités aujourd'hui il
était recherché depuis la semaine
dernière après des manifestations qui
avaient fait trois morts il a dénoncé le
système judiciaire de son pays qui
emprisonnent des citoyens qui réclament
un changement pacifique et démocratique
à sotchi des membres du groupe punk
poussé riot ont été arrêtés puis
relâchés aujourd'hui elles disent avoir
été arrêté sans motif et brutalisé par
les policiers deux d'entre elles avaient
été amnistiés cet hiver après avoir
passé près de deux ans en prison pour
avoir dénoncé le régime de vladimir
poutine
elles disent être victimes depuis de
harcèlement constant de la part des
forces de l'ordre